Wow.
I mean, thank you by the way to JSConf EU
for having me here.
It's an absolute privilege to be at the last
JSConf EU of its time.
Can you guys give it up for JSConf EU?
I can't believe it.
[Applause].
I cannot believe it.
So, you know, biggest JavaScript conference
in Europe, I think biggest JavaScript conference
in the world.
Going to be talking about building a JS engine.
No pressure at all!
It will be completely fine!
I should probably introduce myself.
I'm Jason Williams.
I'm a senior software engineer at Bloomberg
in the UK in London, dare I say Europe?
We're still clinging on.
I used to work at the BBC as well.
Are there BBC people?
Here?
Yes, wow!
I've also been involved in sort of TC39, so
I've been working on the proposal over the
past year which allows you to get on board
all of your promises, regardless of the state
whether fulfilled or rejected, and you have
control then to do what you want with them.
On the Rust side, I've also been involved
in Rust as well.
I used to be the maintainer of the Sublime
Text Rust plugin.
I've since moved into the Rust DevTools team,
and they focus on sort of ID plugins, tooling,
and then the Rust language server as well
which is pretty cool which is a single process
that handles things like debugging, hinting,
and all the editors can make use of that.
So I thought doing some specifications with
JavaScript, really interesting, you know,
working a little bit on Rust as well, my two
favourite things, how can I marry these two
things together?
My two languages that I love so much?
How can I bring these together?
And by the way, the biggest JavaScript conference
in the world, I know it's a ballsy move talking
about Rust, but I'm going to go with it.
Bear with me.
I thought why not build a JavaScript engine
written in Rust?
Take the fun and accessibility of JavaScript
and then power that with Rust, and then see
what we can get?
It was a bit ambitious.
It was quite checking.
I actually started off by looking for a place
where I could contribute to this.
Nowhere existed, like no-one had built one
in Rust before, at least two years ago, anyway.
There was one single project called js.rs,
and the maintainer abandoned it.
It was six years old.
I tried to build it, and there were 650 errors.
It was basically because he made it at a time
when Rust wasn't 1.0 and so the syntax had
changed and moved on, and it was faster to
build one from scratch than it was to try
and get this working.
That's exactly what I did.
I'm not an expert by the way in parsing, or
writing compilers, or any of that.
I mean, I even struggle to read CSS in the
morning, so I'm not an expert in parsing source
code, so I thought let's start from somewhere.
I thought it was a jump.
Doing small things in Rust, and going from
like "hello, world" to full-on JavaScript
interpreter was probably a bit of a jump.
I probably should have done something in between
like a to-do MVC, or something like that.
I knew I was on to something here that I had
a good language, something to work with.
There were a couple of reasons that I wanted
to use Rust to build this engine.
One was control.
One of the things Rust says to you we're going
to give you the control you can have plus
all the safety.
And so I can utilise a sort of close to the
metalness of Rust and do the things I need
to do, and then the compile time means I don't
fall over myself.
It was quite fast, so it is built on top of
LOVM which means the years of the LOVM compiler
they've done, Rust can tap into that and make
use of it.
Sometimes, you can get faster CodeGen which
produces C. There's memory safety as well.
Rust has an ownership system which is quite
unique.
Basically, if you were passing a value into
a function, the function is now the owner
of that value, so there can only be one owner
to a value.
That means when Rust wants to get rid of data
it can do so with 100 per cent confidence
because nothing else is pointing to that thing.
You don't have dangling pointers, or anything
like that.
Currency, I might want to make use of this
at some point.
Again, because of the ownership model, I won't
have to worry too much about multiple threads,
trying to access the same value, and then
what I need to worry about data races.
All of that is taken care of at compile time
which means at run time, I'm not penalised
on performance.
So, yes I thought it's a good start.
Let's get going.
So I started.
About two years ago, I started, I made a Git
Repo, an engine called Boa.
Someone asked me why I called that?
An evil boa in a zoo in Australia.
I thought I'm naming my engine after that.
I'm going to start with a high-level view
here.
So the architecture that I'm going to go with
for now is going to be a few things missing,
for those of you who are familiar with compilers,
but the view that I'm going to start with
is taking some source code, and that can be
from, say, a network, or in this case reading
from a file, basically.
Taking the source code, bringing it into as
a string buffer, so just imagine a big string
of JavaScript.
And I'm going to use the scanner that I've
made to break that down into some various
tokens.
And these tokens, they're basically like groups
of characters that are bunched together to
have some sort of semantic meaning.
In this case, we've got function as a tone,
or fu, or the opening parenthesis here.
We are going to send them on to the parser
operation.
These expressions are different.
Expressions are hold other for example s.
If you've got the opening of a function, you've
got function declaration.
The block inside that function, we've got
some variable declaration, so the variable
declarations would be children to that function.
That's generally the idea.
Let's just step into that a little bit closer.
I'm going to take that line of JS here.
I showed this to someone earlier, and they
were like, "You should have used const!"
Sorry, I forgot.
I'm going to start with Let.
Imagine you're scanning this, so the thing
that reads the file has done its job now and
it's going to pass this through.
The first thing we are sitting on is the Let.
We will produce a token from that.
The token in this case is our object.
We've got the value.
We want to keep hold of the value.
That's useful.
We want to make a category for the tone.
In this case, it's a key word.
The reason I know that it is a key word is
because I took a look on the spec, grabbed
key words and codified against that.
So, when I take a string like let that's got
no quotes at the beginning, I know it's going
to be either an identifier, or maybe even
a token, so what I start off by doing is checking
off against my list of key words, and I know
that this one is a key word.
Conf does the same thing but it doesn't exist
as a key word so we assume it's an identifier.
We are keeping track of the position.
The compiler doesn't really need that per
se, but it's good if you're debugging and
you can output that there's a problem on this
line, or if there is a token we're not expecting,
we can say there was an issue here, and it's
on this column, this line number.
Punctuation gets its own category.
Again with, we want to keep the value and
where we are and so on.
So here we've got.
Some punctuation, a string, and an identifier,
and a key word.
We're going to place this into an array, and
then pass it on to our parser.
This makes it easier for us to deal with when
we're traversing through the source code.
If you want to look at Rust, don't worry about
understanding the syntax or anything like
that, but I make use of Rust pattern-matching.
Think of Switch Case.
It is similar but more powerful.
The idea is that you can take a character,
or anything, actually, and then the pattern-matching
allows you to do some destructuring on that.
You can say is it this or this?
You can do bindings which I don't have an
example about here, or we can say is it a
digit, or is it alphabetic?
This this case, we're on let, so it is alphabetic,
so we go into a state of trying to parse and
an identifier.
And then we take this, put it in a loop, and
of through each character in our source code
and you do the same thing.
With each character you land on, that's a
state.
It's a state machine going on.
If you're in a quote, it's a state of parsing
a string.
If you're in a character, it's parsing an
identifier and a key word, and so on.
I've got a demo.
This is something I did earlier.
I was going to do it live, but Paul Irish
is around, so I just wanted to make sure that
he's not going to get interference, or anything!
This is a quick writing conf, equals JSConf.
We will output some tones.
Very similar to what I showed you earlier.
We have key words, an identifier, and our
punctuation, et cetera.
This is now ready to go.
We're Aldershot Town done in this area.
With parsing, we're going to sort of take
that array of tokens, and we are going to
try to build a tree structure now.
So we are going to start building expressions
from these tokens.
The way we do that is similar to how we were
iterating for the tokens as well.
With the characters, we had some pattern-matching
going on.
We're going to do the same thing.
This time, though, we're able to pattern-match
on tokens.
Now we can say we are sitting on a token that
is representing a key word, or representing
an identifier.
If it is a key word, we can say this is the
key word that we are currently sitting on.
A quick side note about pattern-matching.
It's been so successful in Rust, it's had
a lot of success that there's been, there's
been a proposal in stage one to bring pattern-matching
across into JavaScript.
Keep an eye on that.
In this case here, we are sitting on top of
an "if", and we know our next token should
be an open parenthesis.
I've made a utility function here called expect
punc, expect to have a premises or error out
at that point.
We can then parse our condition.
This is between the parenthesis, and we can
make an expression there, and we can do the
same thing with the "if" body, and that is
the expression underneath.
"Next" there chemicals it if the token is
"else", which is optional.
We may or may not have angles.
If we do, we parse that as well.
After that, we've got three expressions: the
condition, the body, and then potentially
the else, and we add those expressions underneath
the if "if" expression, so you can start to
see the free structure we've got.
Don't worry about the syntax of this, but
this is implemented using an enum.
The expressions are what they call variants.
Each variant can hold another expression.
You get the recursive structure, and the if
variant holds an expression which is a condition
which is another expression that might hold
other things.
The if body, and we wrap the "else" in an
option which basically means we may or may
not have a value there.
It's basically a way of way of us checking
to say is there angles?
If not, we move on and we get a non-value.
The box you can see as well, so these are
like the types and the box is basically saying
that these are going to live on the heap.
And it will manage that for us.
So, take a look at this.
I've added a bit more code now.
We had a let const.
I've added more around that.
If we started with our function, we get a
function declaration expression.
And as we work our way down, we get a let
const, and that generates is a "let" generation
expression underneath the function, and the
const expression is just a little, so that
is basically saying it's a value that we don't
need to evaluate, it's already there.
That is also a child of the let declaration.
The reason for that is that you can declare
variables without defining what they are.
In this case, we are defining it as well.
So we go down to our "if", and we have our
if expression which holds an operation, a
condition, a then, and angles.
As I said earlier, the else was wrapped in
an option, and we didn't use else in this
case so we just return as non.
Then we go into our if body which is the block
expression, and we have another let declaration,
and that also has a concept underneath that
as well.
The last thing is the return which gives us
the return expression.
So the source code that you see on the left
is what would generate the tree we have on
the right.
Again, a demo, so, hope you can run this.
And then there we go.
Yes.
And so there is a lot more going on there,
and that is because I can only cover one more
on one slide, but there are more expressions.
In this case, there's a block expression at
the top, and that represents the global scope,
and you've got the function declaration underneath.
But you kind of get the idea.
So, now we are going to try and evaluate the
tree that we've generated.
And there are a couple of things that we need
to do and bear in mind.
The idea is that we want to walk through the
tree and then make decisions based on which
expression we land on.
So, in this example here, we've got a let
declaration expression, and the JavaScript
underneath is just an example of what that
has generated, and so, on the right, we've
got the Rust code.
What I decided to do was to represent JavaScript
values in an email, and so we've got the sort
of values that you can have on the right-hand
side.
A symbol is missing.
PRs are welcome.
But we've got null undefined, boolean string
number, integer, object, and function.
Some people wandering why we have integer
if all numbers are 64, 64-bit floating points?
If you're doing stuff around bit-wise operations,
we need to convert them to a number, do the
operation on that, and then convert it back
into a floating point.
So it's kind of used internally.
Then we take a value and wrap it in a GC so
there is a great GC library that somebody
made and it was super useful, and the reason
I needed that is because in JavaScript, you
can reference one value for multiple functions,
and so that value goes out of scope.
You need to make sure that it stays alive,
and so the idea here is I can take a value
that I've made, put it in the GC, and that
GC will automatically handle not garbage-collecting
that until nothing else needs it, or at least
until it goes out of scope and nothing else
can possibly point to it.
Manesh worked on that.
He did a great job on that.
I have my value data which is a string, and
I pass my string in, and I now have my value,
which is great.
We need to put the value somewhere.
So I started off by using hashmaps.
The idea was that I had a naïve approach
which was whenever we come across a function,
create a hashmap.
Anything inside that function, I will throw
in there.
This is to get going.
It got me surprisingly far.
As you saw the tree earlier, every time I
stepped on to a function declaration, I would
step on to a hashmap.
Every time I came across a let declaration,
I would add the value straight in.
Real engines do more than this, but if you
want to get going, it was pretty effective.
You can see here, though, that quickly it
start to fail, because we have our B here
that is in same environment as the conf and
the B should probably be removed once that
block expression finishes.
So I realised I do need to have more environments
than just the one for function.
Took a look at the spec.
The specification actually points out five
of them, and it calls them records.
I'm not going to read them out, but you kind
of get the idea.
And is to I then took the environment section
of the spec and basically implemented that.
It was not easy.
It was not easy at all.
But basically, what I do now is I created
function records, I created block scope records,
global scope records, and even modular records,
and then the idea is every time I made a new
record, I would add metadata to add value,
and I would give it a parent property as well,
so that I could point to the record I made
of previously and then you start to have a
sort of chain, the scope chain, where we can
do our look-ups.
If you go back to our tree, the idea is that
I make a function declaration, and I make
a function environment.
I have a declaration, I add my value in there.
Have a block expression, I make a declarative
environment, add my value in there.
So far, so good.
Return is interesting, because the Conf is
not in the turn the current environment I've
just made, so I have to make use of the patient
property to do a lockup.
In this case, I'm trying to find where const
is.
I'm saying can you give me the value for const?
It doesn't find it.
It gets it from the function declaration scope
and gets it from there.
This is basically the scope chain that you
probably heard obviously people talk about.
You can actually put your code into various
tools that show you the tree, so there's AST
Explorer.
I think it's astexplorer.com or dot net, and
you can put your view in there and see how
it would be expressed as an abstract stream.
With all of this.
Let's give this a try.
I'm going to console.log it out.
It implements the console.log which prints
the value given.
There we go.
And so we have JSConf EU.
Thank you!
[Applause].
It's pretty fast as well.
Yes, there we go.
Got it working.
To begin with, I got small things working,
then I slowly started adding some other stuff,
so I think this week, you know, it can do
let and comps, a bit better, arrow functions
were easy to add.
Once you get the building blocks there, it
becomes easier and easier to add more stuff.
A couple of performance opportunities: so
one is maybe don't parse everything.
Most functions are declared.
Don't end up evening being ... so it's not
worth parsing every single thing you come
across because that can slow things down.
Spider Monkey and V8 do lazy parsing and may
not add it to the syntax free straightaway
and make a note of it and parse it will have
before it is ran and parse lazily.
It will check through functions but not actually
add them to the AST.
That's one tip.
Don't parse functions that aren't going to
be called.
All the JS engines in use today already do
this.
Another opportunity is to make use of the
concurrency in Rust, so I can actually break
these tasks apart, have them run on separate
threads and pass data between each etch other.
Got a scanner, pass the tokens across into
the parser, because a scanner doesn't need
those values anymore, and it doesn't need
to hold on to them.
I can go further than this.
I can go further and have a work er reading
the files into the parser.
This is something that script engines do today.
It's called script-screaming.
The new WebAssembly cider monkey does this.
As the script is downloading, it can start
running straightaway.
V8 does this already as well.
A couple of good things - implementing JavaScript,
I need to do that.
JIT compilation, hopeful working for us with
a good package called Holy JIT - I like that.
I will do more stuff on the event loop, and
more tests around that, and United States
advertising tests 262.
That's it.
I've brought JavaScript to the Rust ecosystem.
People in the Rust world can make use of it
if they want to tokenise.
It's quite modular, if they want to have a
parser in the Rust world, they can do it.
They can use it.
They have some JavaScript.
Then I thought have I married my love of these
two things together?
I brought JS into the world of Rust.
Can I bring this piece of Rust into the world
of JavaScript?
Yes, I can!
There's WebAssembly.
I can bring this whole thing into the browser.
I know!
The Rust team and the WebAssembly working
group have been working together for quite
a while now to make Wasm really awesome especially
via Rust, working on great tooling over the
past few years.
Why not take of those.
One of those tools is Wasm bind be and let's
take that and use it with Boa, bring it into
the browser, running JS.
The way that works is pretty peaceful.
You take WebAssembly, bring it on to a place
where you want expose.
Something like this, exposed as a ES6 module.
I thought let's add Wasm into that, build
my package.
It will generate WebAssembly, and I can use
that.
There are some advantages to this.
It is quite fast.
When the browser pulls it in, it can run it
straightaway.
But it's compiled, it's more compact, so you've
got a faster download because you're downloading
less code.
There's still the safety aspect there as well
because it follows the same rules, like same
origin and browser limitations, so you don't
get the ballot box making requests where it
shouldn't be.
I can expose it to JavaScript.
I can use it as though it's a JS module.
It's actually Rust I'm importing there.
It's not JS.
I can pass it a string.
And I can run it.
That's the Wasm attribute.
You put that on to be of the function of any
function you want to expose in the JS world
and it will build your package into a Wasm
file and then export it.
Like this.
I'm going to build it.
I'm doing Yarn serve because there's a WebAssembly
plugin.
That's going to build that out.
Take a look on the left.
It's going to generate a package folder.
It's pretty quick.
I can make changes to Rust code and that are
long-run, and the browser will reload.
It's like I'm writing JavaScript, basically.
Now we have a Boa bind gen Wasm file, and
you can import that
into - we're going to write it, scan it, parse
it would be evaluate it.
And then we're going to bring that back into
JavaScript, and then basically print the value
out.
I'm going to try to do something challenging.
Over time, it will get more challenging, but
this is the most I can do right now.
Hopefully, we get - we can return "hello",
we can do plus JSConf, second function.
Are you ready?
Oh!
Come on!
[Applause].
That's what keeps me up.
This is why I'm in the industry.
This is that's Rust running there.
There's no network request.
That's Rust running in the browser executing
that JS, scanning it would be parsing it,
evaluating, and the JavaScript is there as
well.
They work hand in hand.
The takeaway is you can take the ... performance-sensitive
parts of your application, build them in Rust,
as and you only need to change those bits,
not the whole application.
The next time you're thinking of building
a JS parse er like this one, or a game engine,
it was super easy and worth doing.
It's definitely worth thinking about.
You can actually play with the demo as well.
It's on that GitHub repo.
You can go with there and play it live.
Also, there's the Wasm book, and people here
will be talking about WebAssembly as well.